hagamos un par de problemas relacionados
con crecimiento exponencial y
decaimiento para el primer problema
supone una sustancia radioactiva decae a
una tasa de 3.5 por ciento por hora qué
porcentaje de la sustancia queda después
de 6 horas
hagamos una pequeña tabla aquí para
imaginar qué es lo que está sucediendo y
después obtendremos una fórmula general
para calcular cuánto queda después de n
horas
digamos horas que han transcurrido y
porcentaje remanente por ciento
remanente así que después de 0 horas que
por ciento queda 100 por ciento aún no
ha decaído después de una hora que pasa
bueno está decayendo a una tasa de 3.5
por ciento por hora después de una hora
se han perdido 3.5 por ciento u otra
manera de ver esto es que quedan punto
96 5 recuerda si tienes 1
y estás perdiendo 3.5 por ciento
si tienes 100% y estás perdiendo 3.5 por
ciento de lo que estás perdiendo en una
hora te queda 96.5 por ciento así es que
cada hora vamos a tener 90 y 6.5 por
ciento de lo que había en la hora
anterior así es que a la hora 1 vamos a
tener punto 96 5 de lo que había en la
obra 0.96 5 del 100% que había en la
hora 0 que pasa en la hora 2 en la hora
2 vamos a tener 96.5 por ciento de lo
que había en la hora uno perdimos 3.5
por ciento por lo que quedan noventa y
6.5 por ciento en la hora 2 vamos a
tener 0.96 5 de lo que había en la hora
previa de 0.96 5 x
100 y aquí creo que ya puedes ver cuál
es el patrón en la hora 1
teníamos punto 96 5 elevado a la primera
potencia multiplicado por 100 en la hora
0 teníamos punto 96 5 elevado la
potencia a cero aquí no se ve pero aquí
tenemos un 1 x 100 y en la hora dos
tenemos punto 96 5 elevado a la segunda
potencia multiplicado por 100 y en
general a la hora n vamos a ponerlo con
un color vivo a la hora n tenemos 0.96 5
elevado a la potencia n multiplicado por
100 eso es lo que queda de nuestra
sustancia radioactiva esto usualmente se
indica como tu cantidad inicial por tu
tasa de pérdida que es 96 5 elevado a la
potencia n éste lo que te queda después
de n horas y ya podemos contestar a la
pregunta original cuánto nos queda
después de seis horas bien después de
seis horas nos queda 100 por 0.96 5
elevado a la sexta potencia y esto
cuánto va a ser saquemos la calculadora
nuestra confiable calculadora
esto va a ser igual a 100 que multiplica
a 0.96 5 elevado elevado a la sexta
potencia y esto es igual esto es igual a
80 puntos 75 recordemos que está en
porcentaje así es que nos va a quedar
después de seis horas nos quedan 80
punto 75 por ciento de la cantidad
original hagamos otro de estos ahora
tenemos
nadie tiene una cadena de restaurantes
de comida rápida que operaba con 200
sucursales en 1999 si la tasa de
crecimiento es aquí tenemos un error
aquí debe de ser 8% anual si la tasa de
crecimiento es 8% anual con cuántas
sucursales opera el restaurante en 2007
hagamos lo mismo pongamos que en 1999
pongamos años después
cuántas sucursales aquí vamos a poner
sucursales cuántas sucursales está
operando nadie con su cadena de
restaurantes tenemos entonces que en
1999 que son 0 años después de 1999 está
operando 200 sucursales en 2000 que es
un año después de 1999 cuántas
sucursales está operando sabemos que
crece a una tasa de 8% anual entonces va
a operar las mismas sucursales que está
operando más el incremento de 8 por
ciento
así es que 1.08 por las sucursales que
tenía anteriormente aquí puedes ver que
el factor es 1.08 si estás creciendo en
8% hay que multiplicar por 1.08 déjame
aclararte esto tenemos 200 más punto 08
por 200 esto equivale a 1 por 200.000
que es lo mismo que 1.08 por 200 en el
en el 2001 son dos años después de 1999
y que tenemos 1.08 de la cantidad
anterior de sucursales esto es un 1.08
que multiplica a 1.08 por 200 y creo que
ya tenemos la idea general que sucede en
años después de 1999 en años después va
a haber un 1.08 mejor déjame ponerlo
como 200 x 1.08 elevado a la potencia n
en el año 2 era 1.08 al cuadrado en el
año 1 era 1.08 a la 1 y en el año 0 era
1 aquí imaginamos que es un 1 que es
1.08 elevado a la 0 y nos preguntan
cuántas sucursales o pearl el
restaurante en 2007 bien en 2007 es 8
años después de 1999 así es que en este
caso n es igual a 8 sustituimos el valor
de n en esta expresión esto resulta
entonces
200 x 1.08 elevado a la octava potencia
sacamos la calculadora esto es 200
1.08 elevado a la octava potencia va a
estar operando 370 sucursales y en
proceso de operar otra más
así es que va a estar operando si
redondeamos hacia abajo 370 sucursales
así que una tasa de crecimiento de 8%
anual quizá no parezca tan grande no
parece tan impactante pero en menos de
una década en ocho años pasó de 200
sucursales a 370 sucursales así es que
al componer anualmente durante 8 años
una tasa de 8% realmente da resultados
impactantes